hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play another oculus
rift horror game called bleached
eyeballs this is some messed up house
man
pardon the mummies oh okay ah are there
any other switches that need to spinning
oh you gotta be kidding me
oh my hi yeah whatever man
I want to go back to playing the chicken
game oh don't tell me I got a loop back
and forth over and over and over gosh
shut the [ __ ] up
B is for Bologna which this is it's also
for butts which I'm gonna stab of the
maker of this game I'm gonna stab them
in the butt oh you are the biggest
douche developer ever oh when I use the
word developer lightly good I was hoping
that I'd out another room that I could
go back and forward on forever because
I'm sure when then he was making this
game he thought that the spinning wheel
contraption mechanic was just the most
brilliant thing he could ever come up
with and the world just couldn't get
enough of it does anyone remember when
games used to be fun oh no no oh you
gotta be kidding oh hello babies oh my
god you are you want tons of beaks out
of the way oh no buddy you're staying
right there what are you crazy ah dick